merci mesdames et messiers tout d'abord
je voudrais remercier votre invitation
pour partager avec vous nos expériences
en matière d'immigration
pour nous c'est un plaisir avoir reçu la
citation de république en omettant que
c'est un détourneur de répondre
affirmativement car en matière de lutte
contre le terroriste
il y a un avant et un après l'arrivée
des huissiers sarkozy au ministère de
l'intérieur
et d'après à la présidence de la
république alors on y va avec les sujets
permettez moi un petit contexte la crise
actuelle de réfugiés peut-être encadré
d'as en compte explique large d'emprise
de l'immigration admic dans toute la
méditerranée est au delà dans toute
l'union européenne
dans cette crise comme ''vers de cluj de
réfugiés en province ce sont des
conflits kt mais la plupart des
demandeurs d'asile sont des migrants
économiques en quête de meilleures
conditions de vie en groupe c'est crise
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau au cours
des dernières années
son épicentre se déplacer de la
méditerranée centrale vers l'oriental
mais cette crise n'essaie pas seulement
limité à la méditerranée depuis des
années il a également pris la forme
d'une augmentation exponentielle des
mandats s'il dans les pays de l'europe
du nord de l'est var actuelle des
demandeurs d'asile vers la crise des
balkans et l'europe centrale ne sont qu
est la dernière manifestation d'un même
phénomène
ces mouvements changeant est en réaction
avec deux événements extérieurs tels que
les printemps arabe en tunisie et en
libye la guerre en syrie et en irak
les aides sur tout avec les différents
degré d'efficacité des mécanismes de
contrôle de l'immigration irrégulière
ainsi que la coopération avec les pays
d'origine
et des transits la politique espagnole
des migrations années 2006 et 2010 qs en
2005 2006 l'espagne se retrouver dans
une situation similaire comme keith
carradine personnes sont arrivées sur le
territoire espagnol
dans ces cas l'origine de cette crise
résider dans les processus de
régularisation massive extraordinaire
interprète par le gouvernement
socialiste zapatero en 2005
cependant depuis 2006 l'espagne a
entrepris une série des mesures pour
contrôler à cette situation qui est
devenue au fil du temps une politique
d'état qui répond 600 pillière la
prévention à la source
la coopération avec les pays tiers
démantèlement des réseaux des prêts des
personnes là contrôle efficace des nos
frontières et celles des pays tiers
l'amélioration de retour grâce à cette
politique
nous avons réussi à réduire de manière
drastique les entrées irrégulières en
espagne avec des résultats visibles
depuis 2008 souligne en particulier
l'efficacité de la politique des retours
les mesures adoptées par l'espagne pour
résoudre avec ce sens les problèmes
étaient fondées sur un principe
fondamental
il est essentiel d'avoir la coopération
de l'implication active des pays
d'origine et de transit de flux
d'émigration clandestins ces mesures
étaient les suivants déploiement
diplomatique
l'espagne a ouvert des sambas sade et
des 120 diplomatique dans pratiquement
tous les pays d'origine et de transit
des plus migratoire d'afrique
occidentale et les arcades
concrètement ni ambassade en guinée
qu'on a pris dîner bissau cap bear et
des centaines diplomatique en gambie
liberia au sac qu'elles descendent
possédons mali niger et tous ceux et
soudan ainsi que l'antenne au soudan du
sud
et là également créé automne dans les
nids façade que dans celles déjà
existantes et pour rodez coopération au
développement et des ministères de
l'intérieur des nombreux voyageurs on
est effectuée dans la région et des prix
des contacts de haut niveau avec les
autorités
complément de ces déploiements
diplomatique dans le cadre du plan
bilatéral l'espagne ainsi que le maroc
et la france ont lancé en juillet 2006
les processus dé rabat confort ou
multilatéral des dialogues et des
coopérations comme celui qui a servi
pour établir indie sion commune et
équilibrée du phénomène migratoire entre
les pays africains et européens des
politiques d'immigration et
développement ont été mises en place et
des importantes contributions
financières on était donnée aux
institutions multilatérales de
coopération au développement des accords
ont également été conclus aux fines
d'établir des canaux d l'immigration des
mes nouvelles et des tout
particulièrement des programmes des
migrations circulaires l'aide de
bibelots au développement dans ces pays
s'est matérialisé un projet pour la
formation et l'emploi des jeunes qui
étaient les principaux candidats à
l'émigration illégale et de la frite à
cause du manque de bourthes unités prive
ces pays de la possibilité d'un
développement endogène
ceci a permis aux gouvernements
africains des pré senter des mesures de
coopération de l'immigration dans les
cartes d'un partenariat avec l'espagne
et davy terre l'idée que la coopération
n'a seulement en plus répressives sainte
rue cyr les contrôles de l'immigration
illégale
grâce à ces messire des tragédies you
man ont été vidés pendant que des
possibilités d'emploi et de formation
dans ces pays est ancré et contribuant
ainsi à leur développement
sig nature désistement des coopérations
cyr cette phase solide des nombreux
instruments de coopération migratoire
on était complice y compris un certain
nombre d'accords de réadmission
qui aujourd'hui continue des
fonctionnaires des fans de façon
satisfaisante
l'espagne a signé deux accords
bilatéraux avec les maroc l'algérie la
mauritanie le sénégal le nigeria la
guinée bissau la guinée qu'on a pris la
gambie le cap bear les ligerie et les
mali la coopération a eu une dimension
opérationnelle dans ses demandes grâce à
la conclusion des instruments qui ont
permis la réalisation de projets
spécifiques des contrôles de
l'immigration
ces six romans dans lesquels est
impliqué l'union européenne à travers l'
agence frontex se sont dans un premier
lieu concentrer sur la pâte ride et swag
côtière de la mauritanie et du sénégal
et on était élargie ensuite à d'autres
pays du golfe de guinée et du sahel
cesse instruments on était sophistiqué
pour y inclure des questions comme la
formation les renforcements des
capacités et l'échangé d'informations
avec un impact direct sur l'amélioration
de la gouvernance de ce pays
parmi les projets opérationnels les plus
importants actuellement en
fonctionnement soulignèrent les pas
trois comme jean avec la pluie matériels
espagnols sur les terrains de vecteur
est délicat hélicoptères et des avions
de reconnaissance
quant aux opérations maritimes frontex
l'ex pagne à collaborer dans le
financement de l'opération
ra en assumant une partie du coût des
patrouilles
oui oui je veux venir
m pour souligner que l'espagne considère
qu'un élément clé de la politique
commune de l'immigration vers laquelle
doivent avancer lune une ruban et les
retours et la réadmission part
conséquente est afin de mettre en place
un programme européen de retour tels
qu'ils figurent dans les conclusions du
conseil européen des 25 et 26 juin 2015
l'espagne a préparé un mémorandum avec
les contributions et les mesures qu'elle
considère important et qui a présenté
lors du conseil du chan
du vent juliette 2015 pour terminer à
l'espagne comprendre que nous nous
trouvons que nous trouvons nous trouvons
face à un défi commun qui exige une
réponse globale qui prête la source du
problème
cependant compte tenu de la situation
exceptionnelle dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui l'espagne sera comme
toujours solidaire à cet égard l'espagne
a déjà accepté 1300 personnes
fx heures ni 499 dans les quarts des
propositions de la commission adoptée
lors du conseil de vente juliet 2015 et
maintenant nous avons reçu et 15000
personnes
ah si les quinze mille 15 milles dans
les dernières accord merci beaucoup